why should we have all the fun when it
comes to dressing up well there's one
person here today who really deserves
the star treatment and she is not only a
nurse who's been on front lines of the
pandemic but she's also an air force
veteran who served three deployments
overseas yes ma'am yes and needless to
say she's incredible please welcome joni
stokes
[Applause]
being here honestly i really appreciate
being here there's so many nurses that
you could have chose from so it's an
honor to be here i'm super excited this
is totally
nothing like anything i've been a part
of but i'm so happy to be here well
really
okay well we want to thank you for
everything that you do and everything
that you are
and we want you to join in yes and we're
going to do the star makeover head to
toe
someone you guys are so familiar with is
the very infamous and famous star
stylist brad goreski you will recognize
him
because
[Applause]
um joining him is hair stylist to the
stars such as beyonce
you know beyonce yeah shakira
uh and another red carpet maven carrie
washington yes indeed
hi kim it's kim kimball hey kale
the best brad you're dressing kaylie
[Laughter]
let's just say it's gonna be really
really good i'm really excited about
this one it's something we've never done
before
i am one of her biggest fans i root for
her so hard and i cannot wait to see her
celebrated on this evening um
kim are you seeing any trends in
particular that you either want to see
or predict will be on the red carpet
this year yes i want to see more glamour
in the hair not just you know simple i
want to see a little bit more style
bring some more like hollywood glamour
into it so joanie you're going to head
over to brad and kim and we're going to
see you at the end of the show
have fun have fun have fun
welcome back it's finally time for our
head to toe makeover reveal throughout
the hour brad goreski and kim kimball
two of the best in hollywood
i've been giving our guests joni stokes
an incredible nurse and veteran the
a-list team treatment brad and kim how
do you feel about this well i'm excited
because she definitely has been
kimberlized
[Laughter]
brad she is such an unbelievable human
we just enhanced her beauty already she
is so fast
[Applause]
i'm surprised none of us have seen her
this is an authentic reveal okay here is
joni before
all right
and here is joni now
[Music]
[Applause]
is so pretty what's your favorite part
my lips to be honest really yeah i love
it
i mean
wow look at drew are you okay are you
okay this is touched your head thank you
so much honestly thank you i am
emotional because i i think uh beauty
for me is a feeling
and if you feel beautiful then thank you
brad and kim i really do for helping her
feel that way
but you look perfect and amazing so
please check out brad as the new
resident judge on canada's drag race you
might know something about that
and um as a correspondent of course on
the e-network and kim celebrities series
hair care line is now available at
walmart hello
we love our walmart um ross i love you i
love you the best date in the world this
was so much fun
and
kevin and michelle i just feel lucky
we're family we're not going anywhere
you can tune in to the 73rd emmy awards
this sunday september 19th on cbs and
we'll see you all on monday as we kick
off our second premiere week in our
show's hometown of the big apple
all right ready one two three
[Applause]
[Music]
you